actually bring every bring everyone to
watch synthesis for everyone
Mike I'm here we're here actually not
heavy but they were like like no three
how I fell it seems to me they worked
like they actually work yes yeah but
didn't we try them I like the first day
say over when you're done talking so I
know when you're done I'm done over yeah
Donna and then it starts to seem like it
would like scrape across the sea well
we've got to talk about your awesome 80s
clothes what was it like wearing those
outfits and falling on that set oh wait
they're tight - yeah they were nice
what's wrong with his clothes yeah like
when we had like hot days I would still
the comfortable wasn't too hot it was
like cuz I wonder why like some 80s
movies they would wear like long-sleeve
shirts and pants I'm like it's
summertime wait I understand why it's
really comfortable so what was your
reaction when you saw the monster for
the first time like up close
we were watching oh yeah I knew it boy
Eric he did a really good job
Mario Mario yeah big suit it wasn't
animation like some of it was so he
would that's the way that they want to
do is much practical effects as possible
and they've made this giant suit from
the walk in with crutches and like
animatronic hands and stuff like I said
I can control his finger oh yeah crazy
get your Katie bear get your teddy bear
some popcorn get some popcorn comforter
lock all your windows because you're
gonna be scared you feel like this is a
monster off and then you're gonna laugh
yeah so yeah the comics so especially in
it's gonna be like actually bring every
bring everyone to watch is for everyone
[Music]